MeMerci.
(c(cris et chants)
L Le conflit israélo-palestinin
nene montre pas de signe
d'd'essoufflement, malgré les
ofoffensives diplomatiques
ininternationales.
H Huit jours après le début
dedes bombardements de part
etet d'autres, les affrontements
onont fait au moins 212 morts
susur Gaza, 10 en Israël.
OlOlivier Bachand.
OnOn va parler avec David Levy t
RuRuba Ghazal ensuite.
(d(déflagration)
- - Israël continue de mener
seses frappes dans la bande
dede Gaza, semant la mort
etet la destruction.
C Ce restaurant a été bombardé,
totout comme cette usine,
ouoù l'on fabriquait des éponge.
DeDes routes sont éventrées dans
dedes quartiers densément peupl.
" "Les bombardements ont été
inincessants, la nuit dernière",
raraconte ce résident.
(s(slogans)
A Au moins 200 Palestiniens
sosont morts depuis que le conft
a a éclaté lundi dernier.
L Le Hamas, qui contrôle
lala bande de Gaza, se dit
prprêt à un cessez-le-feu si
IsIsraël suspend ses attaques.
" "Nous demandons à la commuané
ininternationale d'intervenir
popour mettre fin à l'agression,
dédéclare le premier ministre
papalestinien.
(t(tir de roquette)
M Mais de son côté, Israël
inindique que son intervention
mimilitaire se poursuivra aussi
lolongtemps que nécessaire
popour rétablir le calme
dadans son territoire.
L L'État hébreu a reçu plus de
303000 roquettes palestiniennes,
ququi ont fait 10 morts,
etet il ne compte pas baisser
leles bras.
" "Nous allons continuer de
frfrapper les cibles terroriste,
didit Benyamin Netanyahou.
A Au lendemain d'une réunion
dudu Conseil de sécurité des
NaNations unies, qui a échoué
àà rapprocher les deux camps,
WaWashington leur demande
dede mettre fin aux hostilités,
totout en réitérant que son allé
IsIsraël a le droit de se défene
cocontre les attaques terrorist.
(e(en anglais)
(e(explosion)
- - Le secrétaire d'État américn
a a réclamamé des éclaircissemes
susur le bombardement
dede l'immeuble qui abritait
lala chaîne Al Jazeera et
l'l'agence de presse américaine
AsAssociated Press.
IsIsraël a justifié cette frappe
enen disant que le Hamas y menat
dedes activités de renseignemen,
mamais aucune preuve concrète
n'n'a été donnée.
" "Je n'ai pas reçu
d'd'informations additionnelles,
didit Anthony Blinken.
L Les États-Unis affirment
ququ'ils poursuivent leurs effos
didiplomatiques pour mettre
fifin au conflit, qui ne montre
auaucun signe d'apaisement
popour le moment.
I Ici Olivier Bachand,
R Radio-Canada, Montréal.
OnOn va parler à la députée Roua
GhGhazal dans une seconde est ac
nonous David Levy consul général
d'd'Israël à Montréal. Bonsoir.
ViVia des appels à la désescalae
dedepuis une semaine et Israël t
etet continu à dire qu'on va
cocontinuer et avec toute la
rorobustesse possible jusqu'à
tetemps... jusqu'à quelle limit?
CoCombien de mort devra-t-on
cocompter?
- - Comme vous voyez depuis luni
dedernier l'organisation
teterroriste islamiste qui
cocontrôle Gaza continue à tirer
dedes missiles vers le centre de
lala population civile en Israë.
OnOn ne peut pas continuer à vie
cocomme ça. Il faut arrêter cete
atattaque et il faut complètemet
dédétruire la capacité militaire
dudu Hamas.
- - Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
dédétruire la capacité militaire
dudu Hamas? Jusqu'où êtes-vous
prprêt à aller?
- - Nous ne sommes pas prêts à
vivivre comme ça. Ça fait déjà 0
anans que les organisations
teterroristes tirent des missils
dede Gaza vers le centre civil n
IsIsraël. On ne peut pas donner
amamasse les clés au calme dansa
rérégion. Il faut arrêter le
HaHamas. Il faut détruire cette
ininfrastructure militaire qu'is
onont construit dans la bande de
GaGaza. Vous venez de parler de
tutunnel qui coûte 7 milliards e
dodollars. Dans la bande de Gaz,
ilil y a une infrastructure de
tutunnel pour la machine de guee
dudu amasse d'une dizaine de
kikilomètres et vous pouvez
imimaginer combien d'argent le
HaHamas vient de dépenser pour
cecette infrastructure pour des
mimissiles iraniens qui lancent
vevers l'État d'Israël.
- - En fin de semaine, la tour i
ababritait la télévision Al
JaJazheera a dit que c'était une
cicible légitime. Dans ce que vs
apappelez le recours à la force
nénécessaire parce que vous êtes
atattaqué par le Hamas, vous
fafaites des victimes innocentes
etet une tour qui abrite des
jojournalistes, est-ce que
vrvraiment on est rendu là?
- - Dans la tour, il n'y avait
auaucun blessé et aucun mort. La
réréalité est que le Hamas se
cacache derrière des journalist,
dederrière les médecins, derrièe
leles enfants et derrière les
fefemmes et et ils ont commis un
crcrime de guerre double parce e
chchaque missile qu'il tire vers
l'l'État d'Israël c'est un crime
dede guerre, mais en même temps
ilils utilisent les citoyens
papalestiniens comme boucliers
huhumains.
- - Tout ça a été relancé suiteà
unune tension à Jérusalem est ùu
ilil y a une famille de
papalestiniens qui étaient menas
d'd'expulsion par des colons
isisraéliens. On n'a pas le tems
dede tout refaire l'histoire dee
coconflit qui reconnaît
rérégulièrement, mais dans quele
memesure tant qu'il n'y aura pas
dede solution le statu quo va
amamener une tension grandissane
susur le terrain en Israël. On
vovoit des heurts dans les vill.
CeCe pourrissement comment y fae
faface?
- - Vous savez, il y a des
didisputes civiles sur la
prpropriété. Il y en a à Montrél
etet il y en a dans le monde
enentier et dans ce cas, il y a
ququelques locataires qui refust
dede payer leur loyer et ses
avavocats civils. L'État d'Isrël
n'n'est pas à côté de cela et je
n'n'arrive pas à comprendre
cocomment on peut justifier une
guguerre régionale à cause des
ququatre locataires qui refusent
dede payer le loyer et c'est vri
ququ'en Israël il y a des jourse
tetension, mais vous savez chaqe
papays a des périodes de tension
etet même l'année dernière aux
EÉtats-Unis ou à Montréal il y
avavait des tensions et ça c'est
lele vrai test d'une démocratiet
jeje suis sûr que e la démocrate
isisraélienne va gagner.
- - On a l'impression et la
cocolonisation se poursuit par s
cocolons juifs et on peut peut-
êêtre revoir la 4 que tant que
vovous aurez tout le territoiret
quque ce sera totalement assurét
ququ'on a chassé les palestinie,
ilil n'y a pas dans votre esprit
dede paix.
- - Je voudrais vous rappeler
ququ'Israël a quitté la bande de
GaGaza entièrement en 2005. C'et
lele Hamas qui contrôle la bande
dede Gaza et malheureusement, is
onont détruit toute leur
ininfrastructure là-bas et la ve
llà-bas c'est l'enfer et
mamalheureusement l'autorité
papalestinienne qui est corrompe
rerefuse toujours de négocier ac
l'l'État d'Israël pour en arrivr
àà un accord de paix. Le peuple
isisraélien et le gouvernement
fafait preuve et veut renouveler
lele processus de paix pour
ararriver à un accord de paix
cocompréhensif.
- - Avec deux états?
- - Pour l'instant, il y a un ét
àà la bande de Gaza et Israël et
l'l'autorité palestinienne. On
rerefuse de reconnaître
l'l'existence d'Israël en même
tetemps que vous qu'il y a un
acaccord de paix avec la Jordan,
l'l'Égypte avec le Soudan et le
MaMaroc et je suis sûr que nous
veverrons bientôt d'autres pays
ararabes qui vont rejoindre ce
prprocessus de rapprochement avc
l'l'État d'Israël parce que la
grgrande menace de la région,
c'c'est l'Iran.
- - Il n'y aura pas de cessez-l-
fefeu à court terme dans les
prprochaines heures. Votre
cocompréhension tant qu'il y aua
unune requête seront lancés
IsIsraël.
- - À court terme, il faut arrêr
leles missiles. À moyen terme, l
fafaut trouver un mécanisme de
cocomment démanteler cette
ororganisation terroriste qui
cocontrôle Gaza et à long termel
fafaut entrer amener les
nénégociations pour en arriver à
unun accord de pe compréhensif.
- - On verra si un jour on auran
vrvrai accord de paix.
MeMerci beaucoup.
RuRuba Ghazal est avec nous.
D'D'origine palestinienne.
OuOù en êtes-vous dans l'analyse
dede ce qui se passe. Vous avez
enentendu l'argument des jambesn
didisant qu'ils se font attaque,
lele Hamas est une organisation
teterroriste et on ne cohabite
papas. Où en êtes-vous dans ce i
sese passe?
- - Ce qui m'importe le plus coe
bebeaucoup de Québécois et de gs
dadans le monde, c'est que le
drdrame humain qu'on voit devant
nonous arrête.
DeDemain on va se réveiller il a
y y avoir d'autres morts et
d'd'autres blessés et des gens
mamarqués à vie. C'est un drame
huhumain qui se déroule devant s
yeyeux et n'importe qui qui a un
cocoeur à la bonne place veut qe
çaça arrête et au-delà de la
gégéopolitique et au-delà de
l'l'histoire qui dure depuis trs
trtrès longtemps et qui est
l'l'histoire de ma famille. Ma
fafamille a été réfugiée en 1948
etet ils ont fui au Liban et
auaujourd'hui je me retrouve ic,
mamais cette histoire est
mamarquante. C'est sûr que moi
elelle va me marquer
paparticulièrement parce que je
susuis d'origine palestinienne,
mamais c'est un drame humain et
c'c'est à ce niveau qu'il faut e
rarappeler parce que la situatin
popolitique il faut la résoudre
mamais c'est compliqué.
- - Ça donne des munitions à
IsIsraël quand le Hamas tire des
rerequêtes vers Israël. Vous
l'l'avez dit, vous n'êtes pas
d'd'accord avec la stratégie du
HaHamas qui attaque Israël.
- - Je ne serai jamais du côté e
lala violence et le Hamas et tos
leles représentants des
papalestiniens ne servent pas lr
popopulation. Il y a eu...
ilil n'y a pas eu d'élections qi
onont été faites en 15 ans.
VuVu que les populations civiles
etet même aussi en Israël, les
popopulations civiles ont le drt
dede vivre en paix ce qui n'est
papas le cas en ce moment. Ce
n'n'est pas en se frappant et en
frfrappant des requêtes ou des
mimissiles. On peut compter les
rerequêtes du Hamas on est
inincapable de compter tout ce e
IsIsraël lance sur Gaza parce qe
cece sont des dizaines de fois
plplus et ça fait beaucoup pluse
dodommages. Il faut que la
cocommunauté internationale cese
dede faire juste des balbutiemes
enen disant qu'il faut arrêter t
ilil faut qu'il y ait des
sasanctions et moi je suis...
j'j'étais dans une manifestation
sasamedi et les gens manifestait
dede façon pacifique en disant
ququ'on veut que les populations
fafassent pression sur Israël et
ilil n'y a pas d'autre moyen dee
fafaire pour que la violence
ararrête parce que ce sont les
frfrappes qui caususent la viole
ilil n'y a pas d'autres moyens t
cece n'est pas des communiqués t
enen mettant des sanctions et ne
papas leur vendre d'armes. Il ya
unune campagne internationale qi
exexiste et il faudrait que le
CaCanada la pluie pour boycotter
cocomme on l'a fait en Afrique u
SuSud pour arrêter le régime
d'd'apartheid.
- - Vis-à-vis le morcellement de
l'l'autorité politique militaire
dedes palestiniens vous avait ls
agagissements du Hamas parce que
paparce qu'il y a dialogue il ft
dedeux parties.
- - En ce moment, les deux
paparties... les partis
papalestiniens ne savent pas ler
pepeuple et ils sont en chicane.
OnOn est face à une situation ùu
c'c'est une impasse. Si on ne ft
ririen et on peut juste envoyer
dedes communiqués et on n'a pasà
s's'entendre sur le communiqué t
lala résolution, il y a des gens
enencore si on voit les images t
j'j'en regarde depuis deux
sesemaines sur les réseaux socix
etet n'importe qui qui a un coer
onon dit qu'il faut que ça arrê.
SeSe lancer des bombes savane rn
réréglé. Il faut qu'on soit fere
enen condamnant ce qui se passet
cocompose des gestes parce que s
frfrappes israéliennes il y a ue
cacause...
ilil faut que quelqu'un arrête t
ilil faut que les esprits se
cacalment et qu'il y ait des
didiscussions. Sinon je ne vois
papas d'autres solutions
popossibles.
- - Est-ce que vous êtes découré
dede voir qu'on revient à la mêe
chchose et on revient...
çaça faisait longtemps que ça
n'n'avait pas été aussi violent,
paparce que je le disais à
MoMonsieur Levy, le statu quo
ememmène les mêmes problèmes. On
n'n'est pas arrivé à dénouer et
l'l'État d'Israël a prie sa plae
etet il a plus de place possible
etet de l'autre côté les
papalestiniens n'ont jamais réui
àà chasser les éléments
teterroristes. Vous n'êtes pas
dédécouragé de voir ce cercle
vivicieux?
- - C'est sûr que les gens qui
reregardent ça disent : ça dure,
çaça dure et à un moment donné,l
nene faut jamais dire que c'est
nonormal. Ça fait 73 ans et ma
grgrand-mère à 89 ans et elle
hahabite ici depuis quelques
anannées et elles avaient 16 ans
enen 1948 ont été expulsées et
elelle a vécu au Liban.
LaLa mémoire vive de cette
hihistoire c'est sûr que c'est
dédécourageant. Et si quelqu'un
avavait une solution, on
l'l'amènerait tout de suite, mas
auau-delà des solutions
popolitiques, c'est ce drame
huhumain. Il y a des actions qun
pepeut poser pour que çaça arrêt
çaça pourrait durer sans tension
cocontinue à toujours faire les
mmêmes choses. Il y a une
sosolution qui existe d'imposer
dedes sanctions et il faut que e
sosoit Israël parce que c'est ex
ququi sont la force, c'est une s
ararmées les plus puissantes du
momonde pour que après il y ait
dedes discussions. Je ne suis ps
unune experte, je suis une
cicitoyenne.
- - Je voulais l'écho de quelqun
ququi venait de la Palestine. On
lului parlera un jour ça doit êe
ququelque chose. L'histoire de e
cocoin du Proche-Orient, il y a
ququelque chose d'hallucinant ce
ququ'on revient toujours à la me
chchose. Merci beaucoup.
VoVous avez une grosse fin de
sesemaine